desde brasil chile pasando por ecuador
hasta cruzar a colombia unos 17.000
migrantes en su mayoría haitianos
llevaron hace días e incluso semanas a
las playas de necoclí allí esperan su
turno para conseguir uno de los 500
billetes de lancha diarios que pagan al
doble del precio habitual para cruzar el
golfo de urabá e iniciar la parte más
peligrosa de su travesía hacia eeuu
[Música]
aquí la cosa está muy difícil para
nosotros nadie nos ayuda yo estoy
durmiendo en una casa pagando cinco
dólares diarios tengo agua ni para beber
todo lo tengo que comprar a bp
una vez en acandí inician a pie desde
colombia el inseguro periplo a través
del denso tapón del darién las mujeres
llevan a sus hijos en brazos los hombres
cargan con garrafas de agua machetes y
tiendas de campaña
pasando
es muy difícil pasar la selva del darién
porque es muy peligroso mucha agua
difícil wang
y fish en su camino por alcanzar una
vida más digna deben pagar a los grupos
armados ilegales que controlan la zona
las mujeres se enfrentan también a la
violencia sexual y las violaciones según
médicos sin fronteras hay una
aceleración de los casos unos 230 en los
últimos cinco meses
la mujer en embarazo no muere con el
niño se cansa mucho
esto me largo de
la caminata para salir de la jungla y
llegar a panamá dura unos 5 días muchos
no lo logran hola controlado
ahora un poco de dolor físico
estima ese estado
en lo que va de 2021 unos 64 mil
migrantes se han cruzado la selva todos
son conscientes de que si lo consiguen
todavía tendrán que cruzar todo
centroamérica hasta llegar a la frontera
con méxico